So, now you are looking at yourself, do you see yourself, do you see myself, I will listen
to this shit show his name, Balaric, he's the one that ends up killing barons.
This is Fredegern, he's going to liberate his people and start a revolution and suffer
a great tragedy, his best friend and father, Balaric, for making this part up, it's embell,
it's embellished, there will be a QR code at the bottom of every slide, and that bar code
will show why we did that, everything, this is a little pernicious, it needs to be redone,
he's out of proportion, and he needs to look more evil and battle-worn and competent.
And it needs to transcend, a character needs to change, he's a treacherous evil man, eventually
he fades away, these two men are Fredegern and the future slayer of an emperor, Balaric's
dad.
So you can see this has been playing the whole time now, but we're skipping ahead,
I forgot to keep on some of those, so, you know, use that accordingly, okay, where
do they come from, where do the steppe come from, where do the gothics live, where, I now
are crossing the river, we need shots where they come from, the horses, we need to foreshadow
the ending, the final scene in chapter three, after Balaric destroys the emperor of Rome,
going down, you lost control, lost your people, now lost everything, you came at the king,
and you missed, you missed, now you took away everything, okay, we came to you in peace,
and we left you to Rome, we begged, our passage, and settlement, you humiliated us, we needed
food, who you invited us to a banquet, why, you treated us like dogs, but we were gods,
we were men, and you never respected, we escaped, you chased, are we no fools, come for you,
we knew your plan, we gave it up for what we had, nobody will take from us, yeah, we knew,
we knew what were you to do, gave it up for your thoughts, well, oops, battle forced you
forced to end, I'm going to redo this image, redo this one, remake the whole section, this
wasn't an assault, this wasn't us, I guess, whatever, think of lyrics, think of lyrics to this,
you see, because it turns out in our telling of the story, we knew all along, you didn't surprise
us, at that dinner, Lion Man came and died, willingly, you see, we knew, all along, you fool,
and we need a battle song, my son and I, we'll get a battle song, down here, but there was some
that we don't stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, stop, you're an ad
So I'm looking at the picture of the gothics holding the arrows inside the wagon,
and I'm re-imagining the story if it were an ambush . So Fridigern actually knew.
And Alaric's son is, and Alaric is the son Fridigern's companion, the one whose story disappears.
Remember you told me about that person? Think back carefully, because
Alaric is the one who kills Valence, confirmed. So it was Fridigern that did it.
Yes, even better. That's even better. Okay, that's beside the point. Let's get back to the
Fridigern battle after the dinner, after the, the banquet. So I'm re-imagining this. Fridigern knew
that there that there was going to be a scuffle. They staged it. They staged the scuffle. He knew
that they would, that that would cause the Romans to execute the retinue. But the retinue
was coming and they gave their lives willingly. Or they had a plan to revolt at the last minute
as well. But there's some drama that happened. Like, like, like in Valkyrie, you know, when Valkyrie,
oh my God, in my version, in my version, no, the guards didn't slay. The guards didn't slay the,
in my version, the guards didn't slay, didn't slay them. Yeah. No, no, no, no, no,. Listen to my story.
Listen to my story. So there's some kind of a link between, like, where was Alaric when
Fridigern killed Valance? Okay. You need to make, you need to make your answers like just,
just. Just a sentence, because I'm recording this and I'm using it as feedback for Claude,
or actually cursor that will, is actually going to take the video. And audio and create a synchronous
transcript of this meeting and use it for the direction of this work of art. Do what I'm saying.
And now you're a part of it. And you're in an explicit way, by the way,
cause I'm showing the screen. Okay. One of these days you'll be able to actually look at my screen
too. Is that possible? Can I like share it with you? And can you look at it real time?
I can certainly send you screenshots though. That was the inspiration. That was the inspiration.
Those are the gothic retinue is three best men. And we've got to read Alaric into the story,
into this dramatic retelling. Like, yes, at the beginning I will put a huge disclaimer,
right? And there's a QR code. Yeah. You don't know this, but this is mentioned earlier. So you
can actually hide this when I ask you to transcribe. And I'll send it to Claude as well, or Opus via
cursor. And so like you see what I'm saying? So there's an Alaric arc. So like one of the
retinue is Alaric or one of the retinue is the son of Alaric, right? Or maybe it's,
it's the woman in the retinue is the mother. And, and we just, reimagine the whole thing
with more people in the retinue. You see what I'm getting at. So what would make sense,
like historically? Wait, but we'll, we'll, we'll, we'll, no, stop. What,
at what age did Fritigern, like when did Fritigern die? 378 AD. And then
when did Alaric kill Valens? Oh, but wait. Okay. So in what year did Valens die?
All right. Okay. Great. Sorry. Excuse me. You already told me that.
Okay. Okay. Good. Good. So now that makes the story even better, right? Like Fritigern has to
survive. He has to survive this because if he doesn't survive this, and he's the father of
Alaric, but Alaric isn't born yet, or he?s a baby or something like that. And and, you know, after.
But what did, what did Alaric do? Oh, he was the one that negotiated the settlement and he led
the rebellion. No. Why, why do I keep coming back to Alaric? Wait, three, wait, wait, sorry, sorry. So
tell me, please make me a table that shows Alaric and Fritigern with born and estimated death.
You have to estimate to the year, please. You, you can make it footnote with the tolerance,
like whatever, but like, I, it sounds like they overlap. In fact, actually,
why don't you just tell me like, like, given your best guess, what would Alaric, what, like,
what age would Alaric exist in Fritigern time? Why? Why? Because because Alaric
lived in a different place. He wasn't in the tribe, but they overlapped.
And oh, but you're saying Fritigern disappeared from, from history that we know of.
Because maybe, maybe something like, you know, Fritigern is, is like a nice, like a Maximus type,
right? Like he didn't, it was like not, he didn't want that life. You know, he wanted to be a farmer.
And by the time, like he, he, sorry, he didn't kill Val. No, he did. Fritigern killed him.
Well, Fritigern led the army that killed him. But in this movie, Fritigern kills him
in that barn house. You said he got burned down in a barn house. But it actually, it's, it's like,
yeah, it's because Fritigern ordered it in the end, in my telling it. And we have to draw that.
Yeah. And then in my vision, Valens runs to a farmhouse in a, in a, in a Maciara,
like on the battlefield, like there's a Maciara and he runs into it.
Like I just got back from, from fricking Rome. I know this wasn't quite Rome,
but it was still south of the Danube, right? Or where, where was the battle? Where does it,
where's Adrianopo? And it's, so it's, it's a, like, what would they, they wouldn't have a Maciara
there. Like, I guess that wouldn't look like that. It was too far from like southern Rome,
like where the stone was cheap or what would it look like? Okay. I'm just going to show you
here. It looks like this. No, no, no, no. Like, I don't care about these images. Like it was,
it was generated by cursor. It like scripted. Like, I can redo them. No, no. I already told
you what I'm doing. I'm going, I'm going through it. Like I, I actually would like this conversation
to end soon because I want to get back into it. Like I, I'm just going to like- like, like,
I'm going to start, turn you off in a second. And then I'm just going
going to like, basically get back into narrating it. But like, what, what did I originally start
with? Oh yeah. It was just this, this, this total plot twist., and so I, I'm like going through the
prompt for the reversal. Like the reversal is like, like I've been narrating it
all the way to the point where it seems like they, they've been dead. You know, life is awful.
Why would you go to a banquet? And then like, like, basically like I knew all along and I was saying
it in this version, like they gave, and it was implying that they were giving their lives
and suicide, knowing that they were going to be killed, but actually it wasn't suicide.
They had a backup. They knew all along what was going on. That they, that the commotion outside
the gate was actually instigated by the gods deliberately at the ruse to have
the soldiers attack. And they knew the attack and soldiers. This scene, the Caesar is the one
that looks surprised. And that also comes from pattern recognition. It's not that creative.
If you could help me with something, is there still a risk like talking
suicidal or something that was weird? Then let's just think of a new
like techno Gothic, you know, like, like, imagine that fusion of the, of the two musics.
Excuse me. No, no, no, no. It's, I want to kind of get away from that for this.
The song is like a departure from that. It can be anything.
But I do want the, I'm not, no, no, like not that unrestricted. Like don't worry too much.
Yeah. And it's, it's, it's, but it's, it's, it's attacking, right? It's,
so I don't know if that means driving rhythm and like, like, and it's, it's reversal. It's
holy cow. Like these, they actually escaped. And the reason that, that they escaped was because
it was actually a, it was actually a grand strategy all along. And it was, it was actually
probably, if you think about it, it is retelling is much more sophisticated than the
rule of Troy in terms of the, yeah, the storytelling. No, it's not. That's actually completely untrue.
It's, it's actually quite mundane, which makes it so awesome. They were like, yeah,
there were actually soldiers guys. They were really tough. And you thought they were beggars,
but they, they were, and they were like, actually like, and then, oh, and then we, we cycle back.
So now we, you need to, we'll need to transcribe all of this. So this is a note for, this is a note
for cursor. We will need to add some scenes around some of the training that they did.
And so then there's a flashback and that's reflected in the song too. And then that's
where it rounds out to them kind of in, in settling at the end of the Larrick's reign.
So, because that's what you've said, right? Alaric is the one that negotiated the settlements,
because that was always the plan. So Fridicern dies of cancer.
Yeah, yeah, you got it. And then, you, then you're going to, you, then you're going to see
kind of this for a little bit. Don't worry about the song. Like, then there, there will be a song
that finishes this off, which is something to it for a second. I'll listen to you respond.
And I'll listen to it for a second. And Romans are gone. We're back to the step.
Don't, don't respond. Don't respond. Go get this. Did you go to that? Go to that link.
That's the song I'm listening to right now. Tell me when you have it. Okay, wait,
about try this one. No, I want you to listen to it. I want you to hear it. And I'm, and
the MP3 download from Suno is not working right now. I don't know why. Oh, here it comes. Hold on.
Okay, sure. So, so I want to change the way that we communicate right now. So I'm
am saying this respectfully. Like I'm having an experience right now. Okay. And, and that does,
that does not really involve you unless I ask it. So all you're going to say is like,
yeah, I've got it. Or, okay. And then, you know, it's not complete. Please don't get,
it's not out of the rooms. Do you get this? I mean, did you get the MP3? That's weird. I just
added as an MP3 to the chat. I'm going to press that. Okay. And did you, great. Okay. And did you
get the, did you get the file editor sent? Or rather, did you, you transcribed it? So you
got the whole thing. Okay, awesome. It was really cool. So you're online with me. And now you're going
to actually go through this experience with me. So your responses need to be minimal, if any. R,
and I'm going to write a song, and then I'm going to go look at the images,
and I'm going to send them to you. And then we're going to go through this together. Ready?
Alaric was a small child. Alaric was a child when this happened.
He saw this to his family. He had nothing. He saw them stolen. His best friend stolen.
For food or for bread. He saw his dad kneel before some man.
Well, they had crossed an entire country. They were humiliated. They were humiliated.
They gave up the thing that they had sworn to protect. They were, they were, they were
taken from their land, looking for help. And that help abused them. And they would not be abused.
He lost his best friend, the boot and the tied hand that symbolize what would never be done.
And that's what Fredegren died for. They crossed the river. They beg for, they beg for bread.
They beg for bread. They will not beg again.